hello everybody very good morning to you
it is seven o'clock you are very welcome
to join us on the breakfast show here on
Sky News winter blackouts soaring
mortgages two big questions this morning
will the UK enter a gas supply emergency
in the coming months as the war in
Ukraine continues and will people be
able to pay their mortgages we'll get
some answers for you from our expert
team and we'll talk to the conservative
MP who's chair of the northern research
group to see how worried he is for his
constituents plus a new wave of strikes
today will ask Labor's Shadow leveling
up secretary Lisa nandi how much
sympathy she has for those on the picket
line it's Thursday the 6th of October
Cliff rescue more than 80 are missing
and at least 15 dead after two boats
carrying suspected migrants sink off the
Greek Islands
the National Grid releases its winter
report today as Europe faces an energy
crisis driven by Putin's war in Ukraine
mortgage misery as two-year fixed rate
hits six percent the chancellor prepares
to meet the big lenders
Ukrainian officials claim to have
found a suspected Russian torture
chamber after discovering these gold
dental crowns they're calling it a mini
Auschwitz
we report exclusively on the British
rocket launchers turning the tide
against Russia in Ukraine
the car now quickly we've been told
we've got four minutes to get out of
here
on the picket line now 999 call handlers
to join strike action overpay we'll
speak to their Union boss
also on the program for you this morning
Royal relations will take you behind the
scenes of how the family really operates
with the Royal correspondent Valentine
low with Revelations from the new book
courtiers
[Music]
and why this Pink Floyd song could end
up inspiring change for women in Iran
will speak to the Iranian musician
fighting for change
foreign
two big things happening today we'll
find out if the UK could be facing
blackouts this winter as the war in
Ukraine shows no signs of ending the
National Grid set to release their
predictions in the coming hours plus
this two-year fixed rate mortgages hit
six percent the chancellor is preparing
to meet the big lenders all of that to
come for you on the program this morning
plus a special program to bring you on
the cost of living at noon with analysis
from our editors first though some
breaking news we're waking up to from
overnight and two rescue operations are
underway in Greece after two separate
boats carrying suspected migrants sank
off the coast of two islands more than
80 people are missing at least 15 have
been confirmed dead 30 people have been
rescued off the island of cathira with
80 still missing and near the Island of
Lesbos 15 bodies have been found after a
dinghy carrying around 40 people sang
there
these pictures from the incident in
cathera show people clinging to a cliff
Edge as waves crash against the Rocks
Rescuers could be seen dragging people
to safety with ropes in Pitch Black
conditions with many people still
missing Navy divers are expected to
continue searching for survivors this
morning
Adam Parsons has more for us um hi Adam
good morning terrible terrible scenes
overnight
yeah this is a really Grim incident or
two incidents what we don't know at the
moment is whether there is any
connection between these two or whether
these are just a really Dreadful
Coincidence of two losses of Life
happening in separate places but I'll
tell you almost certainly on on the same
background these are smuggling routes
going between turkey and these Greek
Islands now the the Genesis of this is
that these are people who have fled
let's say through from Syria come into
turkey they managed to get on boats
which then try to take them to a Greek
island Lesbos has been the The Familiar
uh endpoint for those Journeys and then
you're on the Greek mainland and then
you are within the EU now Greece has put
a big effort into defending its Waters
very controversially turning back some
of these boats leading to claims that
they have capsized that there's been uh
loss loss of life we don't know we must
emphasize we don't know any of the
background to these what we do know is
is that there are two very serious
incidents in cathetera uh which is quite
a long way uh from uh from Lesbos it
would seem that a boat carrying around a
hundred people uh has has gone over and
that 30 of those people have been uh
well I say rescue but do seem to have
been recovered a hesitate about rescue
is that actually a lot of those people
are in those images that we've seen
scrambling up Cliffs to get away uh and
going to to take shelter to be rescued
by locals rather than necessarily by
Coast Guard or or by Naval vessels at a
local school has opened up as a as a
Reception Center and this is really in
the the inky Blackness of night very
very hard to see what is going on
separately in Les boss it was seen that
a boat carrying about 40 people uh went
over 15 bodies have been recovered there
at the search continuing for for more
people let's watch an island I've
reported from uh is very very accustomed
to to migrants arriving there at one
point it actually won an international
prize for the welcome that it gave to
people who are fleeing persecution
tensions have risen uh subsequently but
tonight is not about to mention
attention tonight was all about trying
to rescue desperate people and I fear
that that death toll presently 15 is
going to rise and may rise very
substantially okay Adam thank you thanks
a lot
returning to our main cost of living
story and the news we're waiting for
from the National Grid who was set to
release their predictions for our winter
gas and electricity Supply could we be
facing blackouts this winter that is the
chancellor prepares to meet mortgage
lenders over spiraling rates on the day
of quasi-coating's budget the 23rd of
September the average mortgage interest
rate was 4.7 percent since then the
two-year fixed rate mortgage has
increased to five and three quarter
percent on Monday yesterday the average
rate for a two-year fixed rate mortgage
hit
6.07 for the first time since 2008 and
the financial crash back then Tamara is
outside uh number 11 Downing street
where the chancellor will meet mortgage
lender bosses and Aisha is at the BT
Tower in central London where members of
the CWU Union are staging their strike
will have more on that but also as you
can see we're also
um with Amanda at a power station grid
as well more from Aisha shortly
um tomorrow to you first of all if I may
um what are we expecting today
well there is obviously mortgage misery
on the cards for millions of people okay
and as a result of that poorly received
mini budget the chancellor delivered
just over a week ago which caused
turmoil at the Conservative Party
Conference politically but of course in
the markets too he has a reassurance job
to do with the lenders to try and steady
the ship we understand that quasi
quateng will be meeting the key mortgage
lenders today the likes of Barclays
NatWest and Lloyds later this morning to
talk through what has happened over the
last few days with a two-year fixed-rate
mortgage now breaching six percent for
the first time since the financial
crisis in 2008 the first time in 14
years adding hundreds of pounds to the
average mortgage bill of millions of
people he'll also be talking to them
about these big economic reforms that he
is planning to tell us more about later
next month with the hope that the
markets will then price those in and not
react as they did on Friday although
though Liz truss and the chancellor say
that interest rates were bound to go up
eventually and that this is not just the
result of their actions in the last week
or so they're aware that that is how it
appears and there is a need to urgently
try to stabilize things so that it
although people will undoubtedly be
facing higher bills as millions of
people come to renew their mortgages
over the next few months they need to
speak to those lenders as to what help
may be available so that meeting will be
later this morning the Conservative
Party Conference saw a lot of turmoil in
the party with cabinet ministers going
off script to criticize the Prime
Minister and a second u-turn on benefits
now expected to be on the cards today
you've got prominent criticism from the
former cabinet minister Nadine dory's a
big backer of Liz truss who said that
she has vacated the center ground and
risks lurching to the right so a lot of
turmoil in the conservative party but of
course what most people are concerned
about is how they will pay their
mortgages and indeed whether the lights
will stay on Amanda what are the
challenges facing us as consumers and
indeed the country heading into winter
yes well the National Grid are putting
out a forecast later today which is
essentially assessing How likely it is
that the lights will stay on this winter
there will be continually able to heat
our home if there is a combination of
particularly bad weather and energy
Supply problems it's a forecast that
comes out every year but it's
particularly eagerly awaited this time
because of the ongoing energy crisis
precipitated by Putin's war in Ukraine
now earlier this week off gem warned
that there is a significant risk of a
gas supply problem this winter with a
possible Supply emergency gas is
particularly important 85 percent of
homes are heated with gas 40 of our
electricity comes from gas-fired Power
stations and while we get half of it
from the North Sea much of the rest of
it is imported from Europe and while we
don't import much directly from Russia
many European countries do which will
put pressure on our supply from the
continents now the National Grid say the
risk of power shortages here is very
unlikely but we do get very close so
just this summer on the hottest day of
the year in July a surge in demand in
southeast London meant they were
parallel perilously close to a blackout
the National Grid ended up paying 5 000
more than their usual rate to Belgium to
get an emergency electricity Supply to
keep the power running now they're
clearly the system is under strain this
trust is going to be meeting European
leaders later on in Prague urging them
to keep the undersea cables and
pipelines open this winter but it is
politically quite awkward many European
countries are warning people about the
risks of potential rationing telling
them to use less power already that's
something that Downing Street has rolled
out so far although we could be seeing
some kind of public information campaign
from some of these suppliers and
National Grid telling us all to turn our
thermostats down take showers instead of
baths and so on and also they're
Consulting on a plan to potentially pay
customers both homes and businesses to
use less power when needed if there is a
particularly High surge in demand okay
ladies tonight thank you very much
indeed thanks a lot of course we'll be
talking about that throughout the course
of the program and then at midday today
Jane second we'll be here with the cost
of living special we'll be talking to
our economics editor that said Conway
our business presenter Ian King City
editor Mark kleiman and also our Deputy
political editor Sam Coates we're
discussing the dramatic economic and
political events of the last week
looking at the papers for either
Guardian leads with Liz truss's speech
to the conservative conference in
Birmingham in particular her description
of the party's critics as anti-growth
coalition
The Daily Mail picks up on that defiant
Liz takes fight to her critics says the
male stormy days ahead but I've got you
back reads the front of the Daily
Express here's the eye cabinet Rebellion
growing as it reports ministers are
encouraged the PM to reverse a squeeze
on Universal Credit and to link any
increases with inflation
you turn or face election wipe out trust
warned reads the fronts of the Times
newspaper the Metro Rifts on the
introductory music for mistrust's speech
asking moving on up or is it moving on
out we picked up on that didn't we
yesterday on the show with Sam and the
Daily Telegraph looks at the prime
minister's Economic Policy their
headline income taxes to rise by 21
billion pounds despite budget and the
star has has word of claims from the
world of Chess that a player used a
particularly novel method to cheat
still to come on the program for you
following those trusted speech at Party
Conference joined by one of their MPS
that's John Stevenson who's calling on
the PM to double down on leveling up in
the north of England
[Music]
and a little later joined by the head of
the communication Workers Union as 400
999 operators go on strike
and in the next hour joined in the
studio by Labor's Shadow leveling up
secretary Lisa nutty
before that though let's talk about the
war in Ukraine where officials claim to
have discovered a torture chamber in a
newly liberated town in the northeast of
the country officials say they found a
box of gold teeth caps in a recently
recaptured area of khakive the box was
discovered in a room that officials
suspect was used by Russians as a
torture chamber Ukraine's Ministry of
Defense has called the site a mini
Auschwitz in his evening address on
Wednesday the president said that Russia
had already lost the war
you've already lost lost because even
now on the 224th day of the full-scale
war you are forced to explain to your
people the purpose of all this this war
deceitful mobilization self-destruction
of your nation's every Prospect
they don't need persuasive lectures on
alternative history and daily political
information sessions
well over the weekend and this week
Ukrainian troops recaptured villages in
the Kirsten region in the South that was
after Ukrainian forces retook the
eastern city of lemur in the danette's
region our security and defense editor
that's Deborah Haynes of course is in
the East and gained exclusive access to
show the role that British equipment is
playing in the counter-offensive
tipping the balance on the battlefield
in Ukraine's favor
these British weapons are vital for
Ukraine giving troops the ability to hit
valuable Russian targets at a distance
with precision
we have to get back to the car now
quickly we've been told we've got four
minutes to get out of here
with Russian guns able to strike back
fast it could be fatal to stand still
no one hangs around
hours earlier Sky News went to meet
soldiers operating the multiple launch
rocket systems given to Ukraine by the
UK we're being taken to the rocket
launcher now we've been told to turn off
our mobile phones to avoid them being
tracked the location of the site is top
secret
each launcher is well hidden to avoid
detection by Russia
it's the first time anyone's been
granted access to one of the British
systems in this war we're not allowed to
say where it is other than eastern
Ukraine and identifying soldiers is
forbidden so all the way from the UK
Yeah Yeah from the UK
the UK has given Ukraine six of these
rocket launchers Veterans of past Wars
winning new fans
the soldiers live in the cabin as well
as fight
telltale signs of its origin aren't hard
to find
these are the missiles it can hold 12 in
total each with a range of more than 50
miles how does it feel when you launch
them and you know you're attacking
Russia yeah
eyes are crucial because these weapons
are in use multiple times a day
Commander even claims almost a third of
Ukraine's successes in a major
counter-offensive right now in the East
has been Thanks to British as well as
German rocket launchers
suddenly a call comes in they've got a
new mission
go right a bit one soldier says
Target locked the Commander in English
says fire
[Music]
switches flicked
foreign
the target is apparently a mobile
command post
video footage has been capturing the
impact of artillery strikes similar to
the one we witnessed here Russian
armored vehicles are destroyed
Western rocket launches a key for
Ukraine to stand a chance to counter
Russia's long-range artillery
Ukrainian soldiers even received
training in the UK on how to use the
British system
foreign
the soldiers constantly check encrypted
devices for new orders
another one comes in
and out they roll
it's a Relentless fight for survival and
the aim is to win
Deborah Haynes Sky News in eastern
Ukraine
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now and President
Biden has been caught making an x-rated
joke during a visit to survey the damage
left by Hurricane Ian in Florida after
delivering remarks he was caught
swearing on a live mic joking with a
local man that no one messes with a
Biden
[Music]
um
outside the house that's exactly right
that's exactly right all right good to
see you
North Korea has fired two further
short-range ballistic missiles towards
this eastern coast in the direction of
Japan the prime minister's office of
Japan confirmed the launch of the first
suspected missile it's the sixth in 12
days South Korea's National Security
Council warning that the north will face
stronger international response
an Irish woman has been arrested in
South Africa as part of an investigation
into the murders of two men in Ireland
in 2014 the 42 year old suspect was
detained in blomfontein after Interpol
issued an arrest warrant according to
South Africa police she was detained in
connection with the murders of Ian
O'Connor and Anthony Keegan who were
found wrapped in plastic sheeting in
County meath
Alec Baldwin and the producers of the
western movie rust have reached a
settlement with the family of the
cinematographer Helena Hutchins who was
shot dead on set last year her family
had filed a lawsuit accusing Baldwin and
the production company of Reckless
Behavior the sachin's husband will now
be an exec producer on the movie when
production resumes in January
scientists have expressed concern that
the discovery that toxic air pollution
particles can reach babies in the womb
researchers at the University of
Aberdeen and hazelts University found
that suit nanoparticles goodness can
cross the placenta and get into organs
of fetuses
you probably say such don't you but not
if you're from Wigan now 999 emergency
call handlers will join BT workers and
open reach Engineers on strike today in
a long-running dispute overpay nurses
will also start voting on Thursday on
whether to strike overpay amid warnings
that record numbers are leaving the
profession
um it is Aisha's turn now and she's
joining us from the BT Tower in central
London hi Aisha tell us more about why
they are striking
morning K well it all comes down to the
fact there's been a long-term
long-standing issues overpay they've
been disputing pay for a while and for
the first time 500 999 emergency call
handlers are walking out alongside 40
000 BC call center workers and open
reach Engineers as well now the core
handlers have the 999 call handlers
haven't taken part in strike action
before but the communication Workers
Union say that they have this time round
because there's been widespread outrage
over the fact that Union reps that BT
has been refusing to sit down with Union
reps to negotiate on pay now as things
stand BT have introduced a flat rate pay
rise of one and a half thousand pounds
but the communication Workers Union has
described this as being incredibly low
they say if anything it's a dramatic
real terms cut to pay meanwhile BC say
that they will not be reopening this
window to review 2022 pay because that's
the highest pay award that they've
delivered in 20 years so
disruption communication Workers Union
are warning of it BTS say that they're
well equipped to handle staff absences
of their scale they say that a standard
shift would see 150 staff members it
working at any given time and that they
will be maintaining these Levels by
using agency staff or by redeploying
people to other areas okay I shift and I
thanks very much indeed and speak to the
General Secretary of the CEO coming up
at let me just have a quick look at my
notes 0745 so stay tuned for more on
that more now though on the rise in
interest rates as the chancellor
prepares to meet bosses from Britain's
biggest mortgage lenders
um joining us is a mortgage industry
expert at John charcoal and that's Ray
Bulger hi Ray it's good to see you and
what on Earth is going on and how high
these interest rates are going to go for
mortgages
uh well actually I think in terms of
fixed rates we probably just about hit
Peak now I mean once the bank of England
intervened in the market last Wednesday
and brought some stability things have
settled down a bit now and so
um we've actually seen one lender HSBC
today cut some rates so uh I I do think
that in terms of fixed rates we're
roughly at the Peak at least in the
short term but interestingly anybody who
is looking to get a mortgage at the
moment should think a bit outside the
box so for the last few years most
people have only thought about a
two-year fix or a five-year fix you can
still get discounted rates under three
percent and you can get very long-term
fixed rates like 30 years from as little
as 4.15 so I think anybody looking to
get a mortgage at the moment needs to
look at all the various options not just
focus on two and five year fixed rates
all right you say that it's reached a
peak but doesn't it all depend what
happens with interest rates going
forward and inflation of course
absolutely I mean clearly we all expect
the bank rate to increase uh sorry the
bank of England to increase bank rate
um and its meeting at the beginning of
November so short-term rate variable
rates will increase the point is that
the fixed rate cost to lenders is based
on what the market expects short-term
rates to do over the medium term so the
increase we've seen in the cost of fixed
rate mortgages over the over the last
couple of weeks in particular is all
down to the fact that the market now
expects bank rate to go up more than was
expected a couple of weeks ago so the
key point is that that increase is
already discounted in the cost of fixed
rate mortgages so if you take a
discounted mortgage you can expect the
rate to go up over the course of the
next few weeks and months but you will
start off paying significantly Less in
the short term sure I get that um but
what in what rate have they baked in for
that six percent do you think
well the market at the moment is
expecting bank rate to Peak at somewhere
in the region of five five uh five and a
half percent and so you can see that
with with most two and five year fixed
rates the most competitive ones uh are
between five and five and a half percent
a lot of that is already factored in
um one other point which I think is
quite interesting is that the spread
between the cost of mortgages for people
with a big deposit and a small deposit
has narrowed significantly over the last
year if you were a first-time buyer
needing a 95 mortgage a year ago you
could have expected to pay around four
percent whereas people with a big
deposit would have paid around one
percent now if you look at Halifax rates
for example their cheapest rate is 5.44
for a five-year fix but if you've only
got a five percent deposit you only pay
5.99
so the additional cost that people with
a small deposit are having to pay is
actually much less than those with a big
deposit
so what should we do
uh well I think the key message for
anybody whose fixed rate is coming to an
end in the near future is to talk to
their broker ASAP many lenders will
allow you to actually fix a new rate up
to six months in advance of you needing
to take it out so talk to your broker it
may well be that you decide to do
nothing in the short term but there's
there's a strong argument I think for
getting a rate agreed now and then if
things improve before you need it in
most cases you're not committed to that
rate you can actually look for another
rate but whether you go for a short-term
deal and take the chance on rates moving
or whether you lock into a fixed rate
it's going to depend very much on
individual circumstances but I do think
one sector of the market which people
have ignored up to now is worth looking
at particularly for those who really
can't afford the risk of rate shooting
up and that is to look at a 30-year
fixed rate mortgage you know where rate
starts as low as 4.15 and the beauty of
that is that although it it locks you in
for 30 years if you actually have to
repay the mortgage simply because you're
saying the property you then no longer
pay your payment charges so people who
are now coming to the end of a two-year
fixed rate which
um they took out
um a couple years ago perhaps it rates
as low as one one and a half percent and
are now looking at rates over five
percent I think we'll see the benefit of
having a rate that's fixed for much
longer and not having to worry about
whether they can afford their mortgage
in the future uh what about going on to
uh flexible rates would you have to be
Bonkers to do that at the moment
uh well but my flexible right side
because you you mean variable rates and
there are a lot of the building
societies who do offer rates at a
discount to their standard variable rate
I think as bank rate increases not all
of those standard variable rates are
going to increase in line with bank rate
and so whilst you have to be prepared
for your rates to increase its bank rate
goes up it's very unlikely to increase
more quickly in bank rate uh more
quickly than Bank rates and I think in
many cases will increase more slowly and
the beauty is you start off with the
rate much lower So you you're
effectively insulated and against rate
Rises unless bank rate goes up by more
than about two percent
okay great to talk to you thanks the
explanation
again everybody you're watching the
breakfast show here on Sky News Thursday
morning let's tell you about our top
stories should we rescue operations on
away in Greece after two boats carrying
suspected migrants sank killing 15
people at least 50 more than 80 people
are still missing
the chancellor will meet bosses from
Britain's biggest mortgage lenders today
after repayments reach their highest
level in two decades that is the
National Grid prepares to release their
regular winter report today
foreign
Ukraine officials claim to have
discovered a torture chamber in one of
the newly liberated towns there
Mrs gave her first speech as prime
minister at Party Conference yesterday
how did it go down you might ask the
papers mixed in their response what
about conservative MP and chair of the
northern research group John Stevenson
uh what did you make of it Mr Stevenson
good morning
well I think the Prime Minister finished
the conference on a high we've got to
acknowledge it's been a bit of a
difficult few days for her but I think
she finished in a high and most
importantly of all she was setting at a
very strong policy agenda one which I
think all conservative MPS will
certainly get behind and I think it's an
extremely important agenda for people
such as myself who live in the north of
England where we've obviously been
advocating the leveling up agenda for
some time it's a Manifesto commitment
from 2019 and I feel very confident that
she's committed to it
did you vote for her
uh no I didn't but I don't think that's
relevant now what we've got to do is get
behind our prime minister we had uh an
election uh We've chosen our prime
minister uh she's now leading the party
and I think she's setting out a very
clear agenda one that clearly divides us
from opposition parties because you've
got people like the greens who don't
want to see growth in the economy
liberal Democrats never sure what
they're up to and labor who are devoid
of ideas we now have a clear agenda and
from the northern perspective we've long
said what is leveling up about it's two
things it's about improving people's
lives and it is about closing the gap
between those less prosperous areas with
the more prosperous areas and that means
growing our economy so I want to see the
policies that will lead to Greater
growth in the north of England we can
close that Gap
and does that include slashing the 45p
rate of tax and also Bankers bonuses
caps being removed
I think at the end of the day they were
a distraction to what we want to
actually achieve and I'm actually very
pleased the government to put that to
one side we can then concentrate on the
agenda and the policies that will
actually deliver the growth in the
places I want to see it so you're
cutting National Insurance I think is a
positive but it's not just about tax
cuts it's also about looking at the
amount of Regulation that there is and
it's looking at public sector investment
in skills in infrastructure and
attracting the private sector which
ultimately is the gold private sector
will lead to greater wealth creation
greater wealth creation leads to better
Public Services which is what something
which we all want to see okay so you you
also think it's a good idea to remove
the cap on Bankers bonuses then
well that's a private sector matter and
to be perfectly honest if we gain more
tax from that we can then use that tax
to pay for public services but what is
most important is about growing the
economy in different parts of the
country I want to see the economy of
this north of England close the gap with
some more successful Parts I want to see
other parts of the country continue to
be successful but we do need to see the
north grow as well okay if it's a
private sector matter why was it brought
up in the mini budget
well I think what's more important is
about looking at the policies that we're
going to take us forward that will grow
the economy in the north of England and
I think I think I know that's not my
question Mr Stevenson my question is
about Bankers bonuses you say it's a
private sector Master quite clearly
isn't because it was the government that
put the cap on there and I'm asking you
what impact that has on leveling up and
what your constituencies constituents
think about it
well I think it'll have a limited impact
on leveling up because I think leveling
up is about seeing the investment in the
north of England and other parts of the
country because we obviously want to see
the whole country uh level up and I
think it's the policies that will drive
that that are far more important it's
about increasing infrastructure
improvements it's about seeing skills
Improvement and it's about seeing
private sector being attracted to those
areas so that they can grow those vocal
economies see productivity increases
because it's through productivity
increase that you see how Society
increases wealth
so I'm sorry just to clarify are you
saying that you don't mind that cap
being lifted
I don't think it will have any great
impact on what we are trying to achieve
which is about growing the economy
question Mr Stevenson just answer my
question if you would please do you
agree with uh Bankers bonuses cap being
lifted or not
I do not personally have a problem with
that
okay do you think that the people that
are your constituents that are
struggling to make ends meet will feel
the same way
I think people who I represent want to
see the local economy grow they want to
see investment into our area they want
to see their own individual lives
improve and that is what the agenda that
the government is pursuing is all about
I want to see the Carlisle economy and
indeed the national economy improve I
want to see the standards of living with
the people in my area improve I want to
see the opportunities they have improve
and that is about investment and you are
starting to see that in places like
Carlisle we have investment going into
our University we have investment going
into our road infrastructure those are
the things that will improve the
productivity of the local economy and
therefore improve the lives the people
who live in my constituency okay the
good people of Carlisle won't carry Josh
that Bankers can get even bigger bonuses
than they did before they all have
different opinions on that subject but I
think far more importantly people will
be looking to what matters in their own
individual lives their own communities
and ultimately they want to see the
whole country succeed but I want to
concentrate on the policies that will
lead to an improved economy in Carlisle
and in other parts of the country yeah
the reason I'm asking you is of course
because Carlisle was a red wall State
until 2010 and it's exactly seats like
that that will have an opinion on uh
Bankers bonuses in the cap being lifted
and when they get into the polling booth
in 2022 December 2022 that could swing
it for them this government looking as
though they're looking after the fat
cats rather than leveling up in Carlisle
I disagree with that because I think
you're actually seeing direct investment
from government into places like
Carlisle I've already highlighted we've
got a Ring Road potential investment
we've got the university expanding in
the area we've seen job creation in the
area and I think what will matter to the
people of Carlisle at the next election
is has Carlisle improved has their own
individual lives improved and has the
opportunities for their own children and
families improved because that's a
critical thing I want to see everybody
improve their lives have greater
opportunity better jobs higher wages
greater productivity in the economy and
also our environment where they live and
their communities are prosperous that is
the policy of the present government
pursuing a growth agenda I think is the
right approach
a little so I'm guessing I'd be thinking
about whether they can keep a roof over
their heads or even if they can because
mortgages have gone up so high uh keep
the heating on uh because of increases
uh in inflation the cost of living and
indeed mortgage rates because this
government was in danger of crushing the
economy
I don't think anybody disagrees that
there's good to be a difficult few
months I'm quite optimistic about things
I think inflation will drop
substantially next year interest rates
are rising not unique to the United
Kingdom interest rates are rising right
across Europe and other parts of the
world I think they will ultimately
stabilize hopefully as the economy
recovers next year and you see inflation
drop that
interest rates will start to drop and
just also got to remember the government
has stepped in to support families and
businesses up and down the country with
the energy support that they are giving
Which is very very substantial what I'd
like to see obviously is Energy prices
generally drop inflation drops economy
start to grow as strongly and I think we
will see that next year yeah we all want
that to happen how high do you think
inflation is going to go before that
I'm not somebody who can predict these
things uh but I he just did predict that
it was going to go down I did yes but
not a specific figure uh what I did say
I think they will go down next year and
I think that will improve their people's
prospects okay it's good to talk to you
thanks very much indeed for joining us
thank you
thank you uh tomorrow is uh with us um
hi um tomorrow thoughts um on what we're
hearing as a result of Party Conference
good
morning Kay well John Stevenson there
talked about wanting Liz trust to commit
to leveling up the policy that Boris
Johnson championed which would help some
some of the MPS and of course the voters
in these seats the conservatives newly
won in the north of England and I think
what will be worrying him is that if Liz
truss is to try and balance the books
and the chancellor has that he'll set
out his plan for that next month there's
going to have to be spending
squeeze is to pay for some of these tax
cuts and the expectation is that if Liz
trust is unable to convince her party to
cut spending on public services which we
know are already very much squeezed then
she will have to go for Capital budgets
for the money that was going to be used
to invest in some of these more deprived
areas so you can see that he and others
in the northern research Group which
represents about 50 conservative MPS at
a very large campaign group may start to
get a bit disappointed if some of those
promises do not come to pass Liz trust
mentioned leveling up in her speech
yesterday but without any detail and she
will no doubt be pressed for detail by
her MPS when she comes to present some
of her plans about shaking up planning
building new investment zones which is
already encountering a lot of opposition
I'm talking to MPS who say they're
getting hundreds of letters from people
concerned about building on the Green
Belt about overriding Environmental
Protections all of this is shaping up to
be a big battle till so if Liz trust
can't do any of that she may not be able
to achieve the economic growth that she
keeps telling us about now all the
conservatives who were at Party
Conference have now gone back to their
respective constituencies of course a
bit of an incident allegedly in a
nightclub that was being organized by
the lgbtq community a conservative party
run of a fringe party run what do we
know this is the front page of um in
fact this is the Metro homophobic abuse
at Tory party celebrating the LGBT
community what happened
well okay amid all the other turmoil and
people going off script it turns out
quite a serious incident may have
happened at an event for the LGBT
conservatives so an event to celebrate
diversity it was a party at a nightclub
on Tuesday night and the accusation is
that there were two homophobic
incidences at that event in one A man
was was
um was allegedly described using a
derogatory word about gay men and in
another instance someone was allegedly
thrown out for using an abusive term
about lesbians towards two women and
somebody at that party told ITV News who
first reported it I don't feel like I
morally fit in anymore now it's
important to say that this LGBT
conservatives event was not at the
conference itself it's what's called a
fringe event but most likely it would
have been full of hundreds of
conservative activists and we've had a
tweet from Elena Bunbury who chair of
LGBT conservatives who said the abuse my
team have had tonight this was after the
event is disgusting she said they put on
a free event and it was
um
and it was very disappointing that
people felt the need to be abusive now
the conservatives have put out a
statement in response to this saying
that they are looking into it and that
if any conservative party members were
among them they will launch a swift
investigation a spokesman added any form
of discrimination or abuse is wrong and
complaints can be made in confidence
under our code of conduct so the tour is
investigating but just another terrible
headline from that conference and it
sounds like a couple of people at that
party were suffered unacceptable abuse
okay um Tamara thanks so much indeed for
explaining that to us set oslo's new
music video posted on his Instagram
account has been played more than five
million times and videos and messages
from inside around have been posted
using the hashtag Hey Ayatollah one
video shows girls in Tehran cutting
their hair while the song plays Middle
East correspondent Sally bunkel reports
on a pro protest movements sweeping the
world
if anything the protests in Iran are
stepping up despite the government's
attempts to crack down on them often
with lethal violence
there is a noticeable generational
divide to this Uprising it's young
against old
this video shows female students in
Shiraz shouting besieges get lost
to a member of the FED besiji
paramilitary Force who'd been invited to
give a speech
thank you
and in this video filmed near the
capital of Tehran a reigning school
girls many without their heads covered
throw objects at a man and chase them
away
for Freedom actresses around the world
have been cutting their hair in protest
at the way women are treated by the
Iranian regime
and in the European Parliament in
Brussels an iraqi-born Swedish MEP cut
off part of her hair in solidarity with
the women of Iran
women life freedom I will always have
Hope and Faith in the people of Iran and
especially in the women of Iran the
feminist movement is not born yesterday
or three weeks ago the feminist movement
is over 100 years old and I am convinced
that history will change either with
force or with cutting of our hairs
the uprising started after the death of
22 Rod Masa amini who died in custody
after being arrested for not wearing her
hijab correctly
but the protests are no longer just
about head coverings they're about
freedoms and rights in the face of a
repressive regime
our sebunkel Sky News
let's go out more now on the stripe plan
for 400 999 call operators joining us is
Dave Ward CWU General Secretary hello to
Mr Ward thank you for joining us on the
program what's the plan
good morning I didn't hear what you said
there okay sorry I asked you what the
plan was what what's happening today
well the plan is is that our members at
the moment are out on strike but we want
a resolution and the real plan that
needs to come into play here is that the
CEO and the board of BT need to get in
the room get their hands dirty and and
start negotiating I mean you need to
understand that these people were
refusing to negotiate every other
dispute in the UK at the moment is
actually involving talks this is a
company whose levels of arrogance
hypocrisy and greed no no bounce and our
members are at a Tipping Point and you
know we're in a situation where we want
to get in the room it's right that you
hold people like me to account today but
where is the CEO of BT where are the
board where are their negotiators
um so you know I hope that you're going
to put that pressure and ask those
questions to them because we want
nothing more than a decent pay rise for
our hard-working members uh crucial
workers that deal with the
infrastructure of the UK and they serve
that pay rise like lots of other workers
in the UK the reason I ask you where we
are today Mr Ward is because obviously
all emergency call handlers can't go on
strike at once can they because well
they just couldn't so so how is this
working
well let me explain Kay what's actually
happened so we gave dispensation to our
999 call workers not to take part in the
strikes the previous four strikes last
two and a half weeks ago we served
notice with them included because the
company are refusing to negotiate rather
than come to the table what the company
did then is get their managers and
agency workers in to cover those calls
just so that they couldn't come and
negotiate now we were willing and we did
offer an opportunity to get involved
with talks bring fresh proposals to the
table and we were willing to do that in
a way that would have brought an end to
these disputes or certainly suspend the
strikes and but the company don't even
pick the phone up the company don't make
any attempt whatsoever and these are
people who have given themselves 32 pay
increases the CEO Philip Jansen on 30
3.5 million pounds gave away 750 million
pounds to shareholders and people were a
real Tipping Point here we understand
this is a really difficult moment we
really do and it's a it's a huge moment
for our own members but at the same time
you know this is only about fairness
it's only about getting the deal that
they can afford to give and and how you
do that is get in the room and negotiate
and they don't want to do that
okay well
we've spoken to BT they say the pay rise
they're offering is around five percent
on average and eight percent for the
lowest paid which is more than nurses
are getting why is that not acceptable
well that's not true first of all they
haven't offered a pay rise they imposed
an average pay rise of 4.8 that's on top
of a pay freeze and Consolidated pay
last year and so that's not a
significant amount of money against the
background of the current cost of living
crisis and soaring inflation it's also
not true that all of those people have
got that money the lowest paid workers
uh actually a thousand pound of what was
put on the table to those workers BT had
no choice but to do that to maintain the
status of a living wage employer so you
know they're not telling you the truth
and I come back to the point Kate it
would be really good rather than read
out what they're saying to you that you
actually asked a question well where are
they because that's what all of our
members are asking at the moment is this
strike a responsible thing to do
I look our view is always
never to have a strike I mean you must
know that these are decent hard-working
people no one wants to go on strike but
I come back to this point and I don't
believe it's just in BT I think there's
a disease in the UK today in the
ballrooms of hypocrisy greed and
arrogance and until that changes you're
going to see more and more stripes
you're going to see more and more people
showing their Collective Strength and
all we want is a decent pay rise this
company made 1.3 billion pounds last
year gave away 750 million pounds to
shareholders prioritizing themselves
over the very people
um that have made those profits and that
do all the hard work for this company
including of course our cool handles
um
okay
um
I'm just looking at the picket line
behind you as we're chatting
um it I wondered if you could
potentially just we're almost out of
time which is why I'm slightly
hesitating about asking you know the
question but if you could keep it brief
Mr Ward I would very much appreciate it
what will you settle for
well I'm not going to negotiate on air
with you
um we've got a set of ideas on how we
could resolve this dispute and the right
way to do that okay is to get in the
room with the company we'll put forward
some fresh proposals we want them to put
forward some fresh proposals that's how
your result disputes
okay sadly we're out of time always
great to talk to you thanks for taking
the time much appreciated thank you